Trump there people have different
opinions about him becoming president
but the minute it happened I thought I
know Dana Carvey zap well I'd have to do
it I mean everybody does it you know the
way I learned it and this is just for
the Nerds at home it's the truth I was
talking to my friend Smigel
Roberts Michael great man he says it's a
little bit like Regis so I was kind of
starting out with Regis here we are you
ready for this about a control yeah and
then I went to Brando and then move back
to Regis so if you go to Brando from
Regis
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe we're all gonna die maybe there's
gonna be a nuclear war come part of me
kind of wants it like this is wait what
do you talk about with some part of you
kind of wants well I don't know is this
this cool wouldn't be kind of exciting
you know I mean we'd be in our bunkers
and Trump would be on closed-circuit TV
still selling us we had a tremendous
nuclear war bunkers are tremendous
Chinese bunkers not so good okay we have
radiation they say Trump doesn't know
but I know radiation we have radiation
okay believe me you will stay in your
bunkers and make babies you'll make
beautiful babies I've just announced
that Ivanka will be the princess of the
surface dwellers
[Laughter]
I don't worry about that don't get haha
don't you get in there yes
he loves what about the fact that he
loves Twitter he can't he's the first
president we've had that can't stop
tweeting it's insane I you know people
are worried because it obviously he's a
bit you know kooky whatever I mean in
West Hollywood they're like we're gay
and we've had maniacs in the White House
before if Nixon had had Twitter
I don't like Jews yarmulke how are you
huh yeah so you know we had freaks
Carter was out of his mind
oh stop I did I wore sweater there were
hostages it was over and he went nuts
toward the end of his first term his
only term yeah he got the peanut farmer
and this is true he used to take a big
vat of peanut butter he'd smeared on
himself it's not yes and just wander
around the White House they'd be like
the okay mr. president I got peanut
butter hair
peanut butter plant and peanut butter
shoes what I got peanut butter half
peanut butter should I beg your pardon
yeah so that we had Reagan who wasn't
even sure he was there well what I don't
know what would Reagan have done with
Isis that would have been now Isis what
who are they icicle what are we fighting
Eskimos who are they what they do to who
when and where we have no choice are you
happy then at least Obama seems to be
having a good time on vacation every
time we get one of his vacations
yeah he's at a half billion dollar yacht
with movie stars touring Tahiti I mean
just other oh but hey mr. president Jed
did you hear about North Korea lamb give
me a beer
[Laughter]
you